[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by bestelling author and great dad Dr
John delone and we are here for you
America taking your calls
about whatever you want to talk about
mental health Wellness money
relationships it all happens right here
on the Ramsey Show well John we had a
really great live stream last night
hundreds of thousands of people tuned in
to break free from the cycles of stress
and money and I I hope they felt helped
last night and you did a great job yeah
and you did a good job too thank you
it's fantastic man hey hey and more
importantly you got my text about hey
bro let's both wear green shirts on the
show so we look exact ex actly the same
it's what we do and my barber said that
he uh he saw you yesterday I like how
you've taken ownership over my the guy
who cuts my hair too there you go well
before we get to the calls John I want
to remind people it is uh their last
chance to pre-order my new book Breaking
Free from broke this is the last weekend
it's launching it is actually launching
next week it's the ultimate guide to
more money and less stress and if you
order by January 15th at midnight you'll
get all of the $100 in bonus items the
ebook the audio book a video talk I did
exclusive access to an online event and
more so 20 bucks to pre-order and you
get 100 bucks worth of stuff I saw it
last night people were uh we one of our
managers was watching the uh our
different book sales and you're breaking
free from broke was far outpacing mine
well there's you know the event is
called Break the cycle so I think people
thought this has got to have to do
something with this so no I think they
everybody got done with Christmas and
they realized I can't keep doing this
the financial hangover is here right so
I think this book's going to help you
reach those money goals so check it out
Ram solutions.com store pre-order by
January 15th guys this is your last
weekend to do it appreciate everyone
who's done it so far Kelly kicks us off
in Raleigh North Carolina Kelly what's
going
on hi how you guys doing today doing
great how are you doing great um so I'm
finding it difficult to have a
conversation with my friend about the
best way to manage her finances since
she relocated across the country she's
held three different jobs in the past
year and spent way more money that she
has along with starting graduate school
and taking out loans I feel like I've
missed too many opportunities to address
this issue but I still want to know how
can I bring this up in a loving
manner I have developed a rule that I'm
still working on meaning I've got a rule
and it's a rule of life but I break it
often and 2024 is going to be my year
okay but here's my rule I don't ask
questions I mean I don't provide answers
to questions I have not been
asked okay and here's why that's become
important the moment you launch into
somebody to try to solve a problem in
their life that they have not invited
you in to
help often that problem that you see is
some sort of coping strategy that they
have adapted it's maladaption is what
they call but they they're using to get
through their
day and um
when you go after somebody's coping
strategy they have to fight you that's
what's keeping them alive right and so
whenever you start fighting nobody's
listening nobody's learning that's why
these pundit shows are so they're so
useless because when people start
yelling at each other there's no
learning that can happen right there's
just a grenade being thrown back and
forth and everybody ends up in Ash so I
do think a uh uh there's two two ways I
approach this number one I am honest
about myself in my boundaries what does
that mean instead of saying at a
restaurant hey honey you you put
everything on a credit card you you
don't even have the money to be doing
that right all those statements begin
with
you and now she's got to fight you back
she got to defend herself it's different
than hey I have this thing where I don't
use credit cards I can't even be I can't
even be associated with them I'm going
to pick this meal up I know I'm weird I
have a whole thing about it and then if
she wants to ask you tell me about that
now she's invited you now like the
vampire like you've invited the vampire
in the door and now it's game on see do
you see the difference
there yes yes so just wait and be
patient partially partially but you go
first too and you say hey I don't know
what your goals are but like I've got a
bunch around money and if you want to do
this thing together like I know this
great class called Financial Peace
University would you go through it with
me that's a very different sentence than
hey I can tell you're broke uh what can
I do you know that's so I think
obviously you have a great heart about
it but you living your life and her
seeing that and her noticing and going
wait you paid off your how did we make
like the same amount of money how did
you do that and you just sharing your
story with her she's naturally going to
open up and hopefully start asking
questions over time and it and hear what
George said one is an invitation one is
a
lecture and so if you want to do
something really hard um say hey I'm
getting I'm re committing myself to my
financial goals this year I just feel
dumb doing this by myself would you join
me okay and that whole conversation is
about you will can she help
you and then she's going to learn
something along the way it's different
than yeah like George said you got some
real problems and so you know you can
come to me and I'll save you that see
the differ and and we talk about this on
the show a lot particularly when it
comes to how elderly parents spend money
and you know like their kids are like
what are you doing
um it's one of the hardest things a
person can do is to to watch somebody
they love make decisions as adults that
they are by law they're allowed to I
mean they're allowed to do it and we
know that a train is coming on that road
they've chosen to drive
on okay right yeah I I have explained to
her the whole Ramy solution the walking
through the baby steps because my
husband and I we just got through with
baby step 2 and explaining that to her
but it just didn't seem like she opened
up to it yep um here's what she's going
to open up to how much you laugh and
smile how much joy you
have and how much how you tip and
showing up and showing up and showing up
and showing
up okay does that make sense well yes
that makes perfect it might take it
might take weeks or months it may never
happen yeah you sound sad tell me why
you sound
sad
um well I just you know I got a another
text message from her last night of just
like how she had spent you know more
money and you know I wanted to be the
hero and jump in and just you know try
to explain to her why that was a bad
decision even though she can't take it
back um and so it just it really breaks
my heart and I know that she's
struggling but if you sent her a link to
the every dollar app and said hey this
app's really helped me take control of
my money it's a free download you know
check it out not asking for money help
she's actually asking you to celebrate
with her
right mhm yeah so maybe a response like
wow like yikes expensive sounds
expensive
yeah yeah but if it's a true friend like
I it wouldn't hurt Jon's feelings if I
went up to him to address a real problem
I saw in his life so it just depends on
the relationship and the trust that you
guys have built yeah and I think that's
it's an important call out George and
I'll end the call with this there is
moments in my friends lives and they
have done it to me when I step in very
directly and I I have to know that I
might burn the relationship for a season
but I can't continue to watch somebody
hurt themselves so if somebody's
struggling with alcohol if somebody's
struggling with they're going to uh with
self harm or they're considering Dying
by Suicide I get square in the middle of
that one of my buddies was actively
cheating on his spouse I'm getting right
in the middle of that so similarly if
you feel this is the moment and it might
burn everything at least you'll know I
did the best I could to save your life
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
it's a free call atle
8825 5225 be brave tap on those numbers
and jump on the line and we'll talk
about your life your money and your
relationships next up we've got Marshall
and Oklahoma City Marshall what's going
on hey George hey John excited to join
the show I had a question about uh just
one of the things that I'm going through
right now uh before this I was paid off
on all the Consumer Debt that we had
student loans cars bought a house
everything was great didn't really know
the Ramsey show that much heard about it
we bought her new car in cash and then
my car I thought I got the deal of the
century at 0% in
2022 but as you know it depreciates
immediately just like John points out
the alarm bell sound now that I'm back
in debt didn't want to be back in debt
basically we're about three months away
from paying off the car so excited to
excited to say that but the real
question is do I wipe out the
entire uh cash that we have and throw
that at the car in 3 months when we're
able to do that or with it being at 0%
can we wait a few months so that way we
build up that cushion so when we do wipe
it out we're already starting baby step
three so what's left on the car
loan the the loan is uh 42 and we
currently have about 36 in the bank
42,000 or 4200 correct 42,000 but you're
going to earn 42,000 in three months to
pay it off no we have 36k in the bank I
know but you just said you're about
three months away from paying it
off right so we would be earning about
$6,000 to pay that off in probably by
late March april-ish you're saying if
you wiped out all of your savings then
you'd only have about three months
left right we would yeah like if I did
it today or if I even did it three
months from now you know I have the, but
with it being 0% interest I was curious
your thoughts of maybe waiting till
June or July I want it gone the alarm
bells are sounding but I also don't want
to have that alarm Bell sounding what's
what's your household income how do you
sell it dude it is 100k uh after taxes
after taxes okay yes I mean that's
that's a lot of car what's your other
car
worth uh the other car is worth about 55
sell it goodness gracious it you guys
have way too much
car yeah are you guys just car obsessed
is this a luxury
vehicle uh for for me it is for for her
it's it's the 10year plan for her car
15E plan there's no such thing as that
Marshall sell the car yeah today okay
why like give me a reason why you
wouldn't uh just because it would be
that's not a good reason sell it
whatever you're about to say wasn't a
good reason sell it it was a trick
question apparently from John it well
here's our here's our parameter on cars
Marshall if the total value of all
things with wheels and Motors is more
than half of your annual income you have
too much of Your World and net worth and
wealth tied up in depreciating
assets okay so it you guys would be over
that Mark and so one or both of these
cars has to go um and if I'm going to be
the the husband in this situation it's
your
car right no and I I yeah what's your
car
worse uh it would be worse I think last
I checked it'd be worth like uh 36 or
37k so you're underwater by about six
grand yeah five or six grand yeah so you
could take six grand from savings and
then cover the difference and get rid of
this loan and then you've got 30 grand
left to now go get you a reasonable used
car right
now right but that gets you debt free
tomorrow and frees up your income which
will allow you to then Leap Frog into
baby step three immediately and if I'm
you I'd go get A5 to $10,000
Camry you're not impressing anybody and
then you still have $20,000 in the bank
then you're basically done with baby
step three this whole thing catapults
you if you will suck up your ego for a
minute and flush it down the
toilet you see what I'm saying we we say
that as two guys who just as of recently
have driven really crappy cars Marshall
so we are not sitting on our high Towers
I drove a $6,000 Civic up until uh years
ago there's no way my car is worth
$6,000 I think cars are one of the worst
purchases we can make as a society and
so only do it when it's a toy that is
such a tiny part of your world that it
really doesn't matter cars are utility
up until the part where you have that
much wealth so uh what is your net worth
right now and do you have any other
debt no other debt like I said the alarm
Bell sounded when I thought I was
getting the deal of century come to find
out I'm paying payments again so that's
well let me tell you how 0% works the
way they are able to do that is by
screwing you over on the price because
when you get a 0% car loan you get zero
incentives zero deals you are paying top
dollar for that car that is how the car
dealerships are able to do
those and so what happens is your car
depreciates immediately and goes to the
real actual value now you're underwater
on the car while thinking we're winning
because we have 0%
interest yep see how they get you it's
disgusting so Marshall you got real when
George and I were telling you to sell
your car why are you so
quiet honestly I was wanting to sell it
a couple months after I got it and uh
just friends and family you know saying
that so it's it's dropping my ego that's
it are your friends and family broke
too uh not all family but yeah I mean
everyone else yeah yeah they don't get a
vote dude I know that think about this I
want you to um I'm GNA do like a Cheesy
thing with you are you
in say that again I'm gonna do something
real cheesy with you is that cool yeah
okay well you take a huge deep breath as
deep as you can real quick and hold it
for like a count of three
okay one two and then exhale
three close your eyes real quick and
imagine in one calendar week this time
next week you owe nobody
anything you have a $10,000 Camry in the
driveway nope you're not going to have
you're not going to press one of your
friends not
one you and your wife are now out to
dinner uh talking about saving up for a
house there will not be a single alarm
bell ringing in your
body yeah we we currently have a house
and that's kind of what I mean our net
worth is probably around
400k but um
yeah uh this was a brand new vehicle I
assume brand new both vehicles brand new
we paid hers in cash and then like I
said this was 0% thought I was getting a
deal just like you mentioned you're
immediately underwater the moment you
drive it off right and guess what it
became the moment you drove it off the
lot a used
car that's right so I'm just going to
buy used and let someone else take the
hit on depreciation next time until
you're a net worth millionaire then you
can stomach the hit of depreciation it's
it's going to feel like a pinch more
than a
punch so I'm sorry you had to learn this
lesson this way man but I'm getting rid
of that car and you're going to have a
$42,000 car one day when you can afford
it in cash and it's not derailing your
other financial goals or you're going to
drive a $10,000 car and be like oh I
never needed one in the first place
either way either way either way or
maybe you'll get a Tesla and it will run
out of batteries and your friend John
delone will have to push it down the
highway for you while you're steering it
you know what we did with my my wife's
last car joh we bought mod $8,000 car it
was very reasonable and then I got Apple
carplay installed for about 500 bucks it
felt like a luxury new car that's all
you really want when people show up to
the car a lot all they're really wanting
is
carplay and some heated seats would be
like wow I'm living in luxury yeah and
breaks that work goodness I open the so
the car loans chapter in my book
Breaking Free from broke John here's the
quote I open with you'll love this if
you think nobody cares if you're alive
try missing a couple of car payments
it's from Earl Wilson I just love that
quote they'll come get they care they
care as soon as you don't make the
payments but I I walk through to the
depreciation of cars John get this new
car purchase price 40 Grand new car
value after 1 minute drops 10% down to
36 1 year down to 32 2 years down to 27
3 years down to 23 4 years it's only
worth 19 Grand 5 years later 60% loss in
value $40,000 car is now Worth 16 Grand
you paid 50 for it after interest and
you're thinking the car dealerships
you're going to stick it to the Man with
your zero % interest they beat you every
time it's
exhausting goodness gracious America we
got to choose Freedom over our egos we
are driving our retirement plans this is
a problem this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camell joined by Dr John deloney
if you didn't know the Ramsey network
has a ton of great shows including the
Dr John deloney show we've got the
George camel Channel on YouTube and on
Spotify so if you enjoy this show you're
going to love the other ones we've got
for you and you can jump on to ramsy
solutions.com and check out all of the
sweet shows we are rocking the number to
call is
88255 225 if you want to jump on the
phones our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services Winter's rougher in
some areas of the country than others
but there are things that make sense to
do no matter where you live and that's
why neighborly has a helpful winter
checklist you can download for free you
can get it at neighborly
docomo she writes I been married to my
husband for 30 years he earns a
six-figure salary and I've been a
stay-at-home mom he wanted to manage our
finances because working together
stressed him out and he didn't want to
argue oh jeez maybe if oh God he wasn't
a brat I thought we lived a good life
but on a recent vacation I overheard him
checking account balances on our credit
cards and became concerned so I started
quietly
researching I discovered he was tearing
up financial documents and throwing them
away so I couldn't see them he has
pleaded 95% of a job buyout and taken
loans on what little retirement savings
he had less than 100K he refinanced our
homes multiple times rut so we still owe
2third of our mortgage after paying on
it for 20 years he also has over
$130,000 in debt outside of the mortgage
I now realize we've been living paycheck
to paycheck on a six- figure salary just
to avoid confrontation I'm going to stop
you there Jackie you haven't you have
been living paycheck to paycheck because
your husband's got something else going
on there's some significant deceit
whether it's an addiction it's somebody
else he's in love with or he's got other
pet projects he's trying to work through
um this is not just to avoid
confrontation this because he has a
different life when we should be living
and enjoying retirement together I now
work full time and he does contract work
there are so many things wrong here how
do we move
forward so they're in their 50 60s
there's been a long pattern where he's
quote handled the money and by handled I
mean mishandled they're deeply in debt
and she's trying to go like how do I
even begin to address this yeah um
I'm going to assume here George that
there's no abuse okay there's no
emotional abuse there's no physical
abuse okay if there is that of course
changes the
dynamic with that said both people are
at fault for here one the husband saying
no I I just I'm just going to do it I
don't want to argue with you and two her
going okay and then 30 years later 20
years later acting surprised oh my gosh
it's all gone sideways in bad right I
would be shocked if this marriage has
been great this whole time I assure you
it has not
and this strategy never works to be like
well let me just handle it so we don't
fight about it and somehow you're going
to have a great marriage with that lack
of
communication with with no Financial
infidelity like this is exactly why we
tell people combine bank accounts and
have full communication right over
what's going on and full transparency
about what's going on in the finances
even if you're not the nerd you don't
want to have to be the one whittling the
budget down John needs to know what's
happening in their budget correct and so
this is this has to be called out for
what it is he has been lying and
cheating on you for 30
years anything less than that bold of a
statement is watering it down and
patting you on the head and saying a
sweetie you'll be fine cuz honey you are
not fine this is Terri the numbers you
just laid out here are terrifying he has
been lying and cheating on you for 30
years and you have played your part by
looking the other way and never asking a
question because vacation time just
showed up and the presents just showed
up and the bills just magically got
whatever there's no way this has
happened that you haven't had some
inkling that things were
off things were off now again outside of
if he's abusive emotionally abusive this
has been unsafe it's not a matter of you
uh turning your head it's a matter of
you laying low so you don't get your
head knocked off okay totally different
situation
but if you both have just been puttering
along then you both have to be part of
the ownership
here um your husband's going to have to
get down on both knees and say I'm sorry
I have lied to you I have stolen from
our future I have cheated you will you
still keep me around and you're going to
have to say I'm sorry that I let this
thing go on for 30 freaking years
anything short of that George is them
playing they're playing patty cake
they're playing cleanup and there's not
going to be be any way to get out of
this thing their marriage isn't going to
survive it their finances sure aren't
going to survive it um they are broke
broke broke broke broke broke Scary
broke for their age yeah that's step one
if if and when you get to that point
where you've had that conversation to
come to Jesus meeting and it goes well
then we can start attacking the debt and
pay down this 130,000 with a six figure
salary you should be able to do that in
2 to three years if you're not doing
anything else oh there's no six
figureure salary anymore um he got
bought out and then he blew it M so now
she works full-time and he does contct
contract work contract works over now
he's going to work three jobs that's
right he's going to work three jobs and
we need to get back to a sixf figure
salary if we're going to have any hope
of cleaning this up and retiring one day
cuz he also depleted the retirement
account right down to almost nothing so
you're going to have to rebuild that and
uh so retirement is it's not even in
your vocabulary for the next decade you
guys are going to be working working
working and I hope one day you get the
mortgage paid off and you can retire and
this marriage can be saved but it starts
with those hard conversations yeah and
this might be a situation where you got
to sell your house and you got to
downsize and you got to go to an
apartment um that's of much less Val I
mean it costs a lot less money to run
and on a monthly basis because y'all are
y'all are in a mess y'all are't a mess
um I would reach out to one of our
Ramsey Financial coaches and talk
through the particulars here Jackie but
this is a scary scary mess and here's
the deal um George you and I talk about
this privately you can when you're
you're facing a scary mess you can say
that it's really scary and do what
you've done for this person Jackie done
for 30 years and just look the other way
or you can stare a scary mess in the
face and turn all the lights on and say
we're going after it we're going to
figure this thing out right get the
gloves on we're going to work yeah oh
that sucks this that makes this makes my
stomach sink yep don't let that be you
guys address the stuff never brush it
under the rug to avoid conflict that
never works out if you are married to
someone and they say don't worry I'll
just take care of it do not accept that
and if you're a person of integrity and
I'll go this far if you're a uh quote
unquote I'm the head of the household
I'm the man around here and you're so
much of a coward that you won't sit down
with your wife and say this is how our
money works this is where we put our
bills this is a and you don't bring
somebody in on it shame on you this is
both of you doing this together enough
is enough is enough man all right let's
go to Andrew and sanos Andrew we're up
against the clock how can we help
today um so I have a question regard
ards to I'm going to start investing my
15% of income into retirement and I'm
wondering should I be using just my work
based um plans or should I also consider
using irra okay so you have access to a
401k is there a Roth option at work for
a Roth 401k speaking I have access to a
457 which is a Roth account I also have
access to a 401a which is a Roth account
is one more of a Deferred Comp and one
is a more traditional they're both
deferred comps technically speaking one
has other options you can do with it got
it well the way we look at it here is if
15% of your income filtered through
match beats Roth beats traditional so if
you have a match you start there if you
have Roth options let's move to that
then we move to traditional as a a last
way to finish off the 15 so if you have
great options in those Roth accounts and
great mutual funds to choose from all of
that you can do all 15% in there the
Roth IRA will give you unlimited options
when it comes to investing so we're big
fans of that and so if question what's
that on the Roth IRA side is like my
concern I may not be able to actually
use it uh based on my income oh you
might need to do a backd door
Roth correct and my thought was uh is
that more complicated or should I just
do the 401 a that I have access to which
has I'd say decent fund options I
wouldn't say they're amazing but they're
they're decent overall yeah I mean you
could uh the back to Roth really isn't
that complicated all you're doing is
funding a traditional IRA account with
post tax ta money and then doing a quick
conversion and if you need help with
that contact a smartvestor pro you can
access that whole network at ramsy
solutions.com and click on the trusted
Pros there and they can help with that
process but it really is simpler than uh
you're making it out to be but if you
got good options you can do all 15% in
there but I love the Roth IRA as an
option because it's it uh you get to
choose instead of being beholden to the
10 or 15 you have through your employer
so thanks for the question love that
you're Building Wealth you sound like a
young guy I have full faith you'll be a
babyss millionaire in no
[Music]
time hey guys Ramsey solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to net site it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
if you missed it last night we did a
really fun live stream our biggest ever
called Break the cycle and if you did
miss it don't feel too bad cuz you can
actually go to Ramy solutions.com
breakthe cycle and watch the Replay for
free it's a little over an hour long and
uh it was a killer night with Jade
warshaw Rachel Cruz Dave Ramsey myself
Dr John deloney helping people you know
kind of lose the Eeyore spirit animal
and go like yeah I'm going to do it this
year regardless of the cycle I've been
in for how long I've been in it and what
I'm feeling things are going to be
different this year and we gave you guys
some tactical hope-filled advice and so
go check it out ramsy solutions.com
SL breakthe cycle if you want to watch
back that live stream Shawn is in
Jacksonville up next Sean how can we
help hey how's it going great how are
you uh I'm a little anxious I got just a
guy for
you yeah doc um I was hoping to be able
to talk with you uh so my wife and I
about a year ago did FPU and uh we're
making progress we're they got the car
almost paid off we got a personal loan
that we're going to start working on
real hard uh beginning of this year but
we still have the student loans so
that's
90k and what what'd you get him
in my my wife got him uh pursuing a
degree in uh speech language pathology
okay is she doing Speech Pathology
now yeah so she's working so so we got a
kid at home he's he's almost two and we
got another one on the way and and
um well so
my the way I the way it's working now
we're we're working she's working now to
help pay off these two smaller debts and
then I'm going to be the only one
working after the new uh baby comes
which I'm fine with because someone's
got to take care of the kids we can't
afford child care and my question really
sits on this as a
father as the head of the household I'm
working 40 plus hours a week Monday
through
Friday I'm uh I'm trying to be very
available on the weekends but I don't
want to sit in this forever I wanna I
want this debt gone I want to be free I
want our family free of
this I don't want to be a bad father I
don't want to be a bad
husband
um should I be working extra on
Saturdays and a second job I mean just
to give you some context I'm a
structural engineer and I make north of
90k a
year so um one dude thank you for your
heart man like I can tell this is
Weighing on you heavy and you want to be
a good dad and you want to be a good
husband and um I wish everybody came to
the table with your spirit okay what I'm
going to tell you it's pretty hard
thinking it's just pretty hard and um so
I'm going to be as direct as I can
because we don't have a ton of time is
that cool that's cool all right um
number one I'm always very um hesitant
or avoidant of either or situations you
have backed yourself into a corner and
you've created a bunch of truths for
your home we cannot afford child care my
wife will not work I am the head so
either I work 40 hours a week and I'm a
crummy dad and husband or I work a whole
whole bunch to get the stuff paid off
and I'm a bad crummy
husband here's the truth or if to use my
language here's you choosing reality
together you and your wife have created
a financial reality for your
home that your bodies cannot accept
cannot exist
in y'all are broke you owe $90,000 and
she has a graduate degree in your
structural engineer you're two very
brilliant very successful people and yet
you can't breathe financially true or
false it's pretty true true okay so when
we make declarative statements like I'm
not going to x y and
z um the math doesn't care what you
declare it's a good rhyme I should
probably write that down on a t-shirt
the sounds to very George
camell so here if I'm if if me and my
wife are in a similar situation
I would reframe our language she wants
to stay home you want her to stay
home yes but you make $90,000 and she
can make 665 to
$85,000 and together in 12 months of
scorched Earth living you could have a
most of this paid off all of it and that
means somebody's watching the
baby or you can figure out XY and you
see what I'm saying
yeah um but you're leaving one of your
huge weapons Financial weapons at home
heading off into a war that y'all
started which is going to leave just Dad
to get shot at and beat up the whole
time and you're placed in an impossible
position which is I have to work 90
hours a week which by the way 40 is not
going to cut it here yes you got to work
Saturdays you got to work Sundays y'all
owe six figures in debt y'all are broke
okay you gotta do what you got to do
what you got to do what you got to
do and um
man it's going to be tough to be a whole
present
dad and it's going to be tough for her
to be a whole present stay-at-home mom
with no support and assistance from you
right so y'all doing this together and
taking a hard it's going to suck for
everybody on the front end but man y'all
get through this thing faster it's the
Buffalo running through the storm y'all
both link arms y'all run straight into
the middle of this thing no it's not how
we wanted it but this is the world we
created for ourselves by borrowing all
this money and now we're going to get
through it together as fast as humanly
possible and we're going to work way out
the
backside so how does that
sound sounds tough yeah um I I feel feel
like I'm the stronger one uh in the
relationship that uh what does that mean
what does that mean it means it means
that when it's when it's
late I I'm I'm willing to keep
going uh I'm willing to uh I mean she's
got she got her Talent she's she's great
with our son she's she's a wonderful
mother she's excellent wife but when it
comes
to buckling down to to
spend the extra hours
to keep working in the we hours T night
to to keep going to push I mean maybe I
I do it un healthfully I push myself too
much and too hard uh sometimes and I I
feel like I I'm more capable of it I
would disagree with that you might be
able to push forward you might be able
to push forward without a
goal but I I I mean if she gets through
graduate school and speech path that's a
tough program and working with those
kids and families or with the geriatrics
every single day is tough she because
she's tough she's delivered a baby yeah
she's made a human dude goodness gra
she's making a second one the uh but
here's where it often people often run
out of gas when there's not a ending
sight yeah the question question is you
want to struggle for the next 2 years or
15 and so that's what we're trying to
help you with is it's going to be
stressful either way we just want you to
solve for Freedom a whole lot faster
yeah there's the the phrase we use
around here is choose your hard it's
there's not an easy path here here's
what we see all the time though one of
you goes all
in and you work 75 hours a week you're a
structural engineer and then you're
driving Uber to the airports on Saturday
mornings at 5:00 a.m. and you get some
side hustle gig and then you deliver
pizzas on Sundays and you do that and
you're a grinder and so you'll do it for
months and you'll get little gulps of
air with your new kids with your kids
and your wife will start to resent the
fact that she's doing all of this by
herself that her husband hasn't changed
a single diaper you're going to start
resenting her and this whole situation
because you haven't got to change one
single diaper and you miss your
family and then the air conditioner
breaks and then you put it on the credit
card cuz cuz you have to you got two
babies in your house and you see how
this thing just keeps going and going
that's why we tell everybody run as fast
as you freaking can through
this Sean what's left on the car
loan uh three 3,000 and what in the
personal
loan uh 10 okay so 103,000 is what you
owe you make 90 she works fre Year you
guys can clean this up fairly quickly
and that might mean we got to do the
math and go listen day even after
daycare we'll still make an extra 500
bucks a month great that's 6 grand a
year to clean this mess up faster so I'd
sit down with her and have these hard
conversations and know that you guys are
a team you're not going at each other
but yes you're going to have to work
multiple jobs over the next couple of
years to get this knocked out that does
not make you a bad dad doing what you
have to do is for your family to be safe
that makes you a good man that puts this
hour of the ramsy show in the
books
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by the one and only Dr John deloney and
we're taking your calls at
5225 John you ready to do this I am
ready to do this just see for paying
attention always here we go we're
Kicking It Off with Ben in Atlanta
Georgia Ben how can we help
today hey uh I was hoping for some
advice um so I'm in law school right now
and uh I'll graduate this may and I've
got this kind of impending awkward
financial situation where after I
graduate I have to take a few months to
study for the bar and then take the bar
exam and that's be pretty much full-time
so I'm not going to have much or any
money coming in but I'm still going to
have expenses and and and talking to
people about how they pay for that you
know some people take out student loan
some people put it on credit card uh I
also have some raw di contributions I
was think about maybe pulling from but I
was just wondering what your advice is
to to deal with that sort of
situation man uh I would one I would
tell you it's not I I was a DEA students
at a law school for years it's not kind
of a part a full-time job it's a th%
it's two full-time jobs and then a
nighttime time job we study for the bar
right what kind of law are you going to
do
man um uh Public Finance municipal bonds
good for you man cool very cool way to
go um are you in any debt right now
probably a billion
dollars I have no student debt um I've
got uh a little over $3,000 in credit
card debt um how'd you get through law
school with no student
debt uh my undergrad to a was free um
the state of Georgia Lottery paid for it
uh and then um my law school has been
cheap a little less than $3,000 a
semester after scholarships uh and I I
worked in the Summers and I worked
parttime awesome dude that's amazing so
you're got three grand in credit card
debt anything
else um no and I'll say so um 2500 of
that 3,000 is uh interest free until
so I was kind of just putting off paying
that until uh after I graduated but um
that's no no other de how much do you
have in the
bank um I have uh in cash savings uh I
think
$1,200 um and then I've got my IRA Okay
so until you have to quit working how
much could you save up if you just did
nothing else but save up stack up
cash yeah
um right now after tax uh I make um and
after rent I'm bringing home about 500
bucks a month um and so how many hours
is that that's after rent and
everything yeah I I work about 15 hours
a week
um uh so what was your other question
but you're saying your net income is 500
bucks or you saying after all your bills
you have 500 bucks after after rent
utilities um and then and then my yeah
so so I I I get paid 30 bucks an hour uh
I'm able to work about 15 hours a week
so it's around 1,800 uh but then I'm I'm
a contractor I have to pay
self-employment taxes and then my rent
is um like 1300 Bas D let's flip it
around this way um between graduation
are you g to take the summer
bar I am yeah okay so you need two to
three months living expenses right right
you basically have a five month
Runway depending on how difficult your
3L year is going to be some folks set
their their second semester 3L year up
to go ahead and do clinics and it's kind
of it's easier some of y'all wait and
pile everything up on that last semester
and it is a nightmare what have you
done uh it's fairly light I have two
classes a clinic and a mini course oh
okay so I I I don't want to over
dramatize it but it's really a math
problem that you have four to five
months to solve
and are you you're $330 an hour are you
clerking right now somewhere yeah at a
law fir okay um you may have to for five
months swallow your pride and deliver
pizzas at
night okay which sucks but I would put a
dollar amount what is it going to take
you to survive for two and a half months
is that six grand yeah four grand what's
your rent expenses utilities and then
can you put that money in a bank by the
time you
graduate
okay I think this is very doable you got
five months to save up a few grand you
know say another five grand on top of
the money you have and uh you can make
if this is kind of a storm mode you
could pause and and make minimum
payments on the debt but I'd rather just
get this credit card debt out of my life
and have all my income at my disposal do
you already have a job uh lined
up uh yeah um I I have to start by
September 1st uh I can ask to start
early so it'll probably start sometime
in August okay do you um
is is a public service job or is it a
billable hour job billable hour what's
your what what you billing out
at uh I'm not sure exactly what they're
going to BU me out no I mean what what
what's your what hours did you sign up
for um working at The Firm yeah yeah um
how many hours how many hours do you
agree to 22
21 uh they didn't specifying a contract
oh they Haven and the reason I'm asking
that is this if you sign up for 2,200
hours a year
you just signed away your life and so
I'm going to tell you I would get this
stuff out of the way as quickly as
possible and build in some margin so you
can exhale between the bar and when you
start if you signed up for 1,700 hours
it's going to be a much slower Pace it's
going to be a different kind of life and
man you can go from the bar to a couple
of weeks off to go see your family and
then head right into work see you see
what I'm saying that's what I'm getting
at but this I don't over complicate this
man it's a brother it's a math problem
it's a math problem that you can reverse
engineer and you got a pretty good
Runway and you're work working hard and
you have done the hard work on your
first two years of law school so to set
yourself up for a perfect position and
you're going to be the nerdy law school
kid everyone's be like dude why aren't
you and like cuz I'm not going to go
into debt I'm proud of you man good for
you good for you you're going to be in a
very different place than your peers by
the way George can we just say
this the Georgia promise I'm making up
the name of it I don't know what it is
but public school went for free then
went to law school and worked really
like has done it all you can't do that
bro three grand did say a semester after
scholarships you after scholarships yeah
I worked real hard dude you've done it
the right way I'm proud of you man it's
awesome you're living proof that you
don't have to go 400 Grand into debt to
be a lawyer yeah yeah good for you man
we believe in you Ben you got this
man that's sorry that was a lot of nerd
speak there sorry no well you come from
that the education world and you were at
a law school so I was excited to have
your take cuz you've seen the inside and
seen people make really bad decisions
and a lot of law uh you know positions
they don't pay these giant six figure
salaries yeah yeah the average law the
average salary of a lawyer has
definitely plummeted and so the ROI to
go to school and spend 300 grand for a
law degree and then go and leave and
make 60 it doesn't make sense well and I
I he's asking a great question and I
think every grad student especially but
every student should ask this question
um you get done with law school and then
they tell you oh well you got the bar
exam everyone knows about the bar exam
but they don't realize oh you can't
you're not working and so then you
people find themselves how am I going to
eat for the next two months more
Monopoly money from Sally M then it's
well you got to take another loan just
to cover that and then how who's going
to pay for your bar prep course all of
this is a math problem that you got to
solve on the front end if you can right
so good for you Ben I'm proud of you
brother this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi re finances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
free call at
8825 5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Beck is in
Denver Beck what's going
on hi hey thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can John and I
help yeah so uh my wife and I started a
business last year uh flipping like
liquidation pallets for major retailers
we generated about
$180,000 in just8 month doing that and
uh I at that time uh my wife was working
at an insurance company and she quit her
job uh to focus on the business um but I
have a full-time job at a software
company working as a consultant and I
make about $82,000 there though my
question is should I quit my full-time
job at the software company and focused
my time on our business as well since we
have this great traction going right now
how consistent has this been month-to
month it has been really consistent
lately it has uh been generating about
20 to $25,000 a month goodness gra and
that's just that's just net um after you
know shipping and all the fees that we
pay on the e-commerce side wow and how
much time is this taking you guys how
many hours a
week a week I would say uh well uh I
usually put in whatever time I have
after work and my wife uh puts all of
her time into that so I would say about
40 to 45
hours okay and money aside is this
something you want to do do you want to
get out of the software game and get
into liquidation flipping business long
term yeah absolutely I I love doing it
it just almost doesn't feel like work
when I do it I we you know receive
shipments and at the end of the day I
just have like a little bit more um
satisfaction of doing this job where I
actually have labor while in my 905 job
at the software compan is just zoom
calls you know it there's really not
that labor gratification at the end of
the day okay and you're doing this all
debt-free you're buying all these
pallets and
cash yeah so um I well both of us had
about uh $15,000 starting off in debt
and credit cards and I started watching
the rangy show and uh you know the debt
is you know it just came to learn that
it's not really good so I ended up
paying all the credit card debt um my
wife has about $88,000 in student loans
uh but apart from that we are pretty
much debt free yeah I'd pay off all your
debt get an emergency fund and at that
point you've got some Financial
Foundation under you to quit the
software gig and go into this full-time
but you could pay off this debt today
probably I'm guessing you got some money
in
savings yeah yeah we have about $80,000
and that's my next question is should I
reinvest it into back into the business
right buy more pallets or um you know
let's separate your personal and
business right now so let's say you pay
off all your debt and then set aside 3
to six months of expenses let's lean 6
months of personal expenses then we're
going to create you already have a
business bank account you're doing this
all through yes do you have a formal you
know do you set up an LLC or
something yes y okay so on that side you
can have some cash reserves and as you
get money in there you can then go buy
more pallets and invest it back into the
business and do it all with cash I think
that's really
wise so you guys can do this I mean very
soon you got 80,000 in the bank I would
use that to set up yourselves personally
on a on a good Financial standing and
then whatever is left over we can
reinvest in the business what do you
think John I don't see any red flags
here to jump you guys have done it the
right way you're cash flowing in this
thing it's making you know multitudes
more than your day jobs what why are you
nervous to leave your day job like
what's your hesitancy it's just I I went
to college for four years my Dad paid
all my tuition so I didn't have to get
student loan it's just quitting my job
kind of feels like a slap in my dad's
face just you know saying hey I didn't
end up using the degree at the end of
the day what did you learn from that
degree uh well I graduated with a
computer science degree so I have uh you
know programming skills uh and yeah are
you are you making an extraordinary
household income on
e-commerce yes yeah I would argue that
it's connected you honoring your father
by saying dad you taught me a lot of
skills you you allowed me to go get an
education some of which here here's the
here's the big fallacy dude A lot of
people are like dude I'm not getting a
degree cuz I don't even use that degree
bull crap you learned how to read you
learn how to go uh do different projects
for different professors which were
different bosses in college you learned
how to do different programs you learned
how to think for yourself how to get
around and cut Corners so you could get
an A even though you didn't want to do
all the work right you learned a whole
whole bunch through that
process and so your dad's money is not
wasted in fact I'm just telling you as a
dad if I paid for my son's school and he
went and got a degree and worked really
hard in that degree and then hustled and
created a business on the side that
ended up making exponentially more money
and he came to me and said dad I'm going
all in on my own business that makes a
jillion dollars that me and my wife do
together I would be so overcome with
pride for my son I'd be so proud of him
I think he was I would have thought the
the amount of money I put in college
that he is Roi to create a life for him
that I didn't have for myself dude I'm
just I'm like I would be beaming for him
but mostly because he took what the
small amount I gave him and he's made it
uh so much more now he can give in his
community he can be he can build an
amazing business to serve people see
what I'm
saying yeah yeah I totally understand
and that's what my thinking has been
it's just like I need confirmation on
whether what I'm doing is right I just I
just want to make sure that security
yeah that your hesitancy isn't no this
has been like a fun cool two years and
then an AI bot's going to come out and
do this thing in one second what it
takes us a week to do and this gig's
going to be up because if that's the
case dude you had an awesome fun ride
for a few years make a bunch of money
pay off your house and then it's a it
was a cool ride if you think no no no
we've stumbled onto something for real
then man congratulations dude
congratulations awesome thank you hope
that helps back thank you so much for
theice yeah absolutely and George I I
love that Dave tells a story all the
time about his uh I think this his
grandma used to always ask him like when
are you gonna get a real job Dave right
cuz he was doing the Dave Ramsey thing
but when he going to get a real job and
with ever understanding like oh dudee
I'm just I'm not working for a
corporation I'm creating one I'm
building my well the older Generations
you know they're they're used to a
traditional career so when you tell them
John's like ah yeah I'm a YouTuber
you're like they don't know what that
means you know and so I think that's the
hard part is just helping parents
understand what the heck this is you
know if I told my parents I'm running an
e-commerce liquidation business my mom's
head would spin right she would have no
clue my sweet Middle Eastern Arabic mom
was like what what did that mean you
know and so I think that's part of the
problem is just explaining to our
parents the new fangled career paths
that are out there today um which you
know that's a fine problem to have we
can solve that in a conversation I I
flip things on Amazon Mom oh okay cool
that's great I know that means cuz what
they really care about they're like I
make $250,000 doing this Mom they're
like oh yay good you know how Walmart
buys things from the uh the distribution
house and then marks it up and sells it
to you at their store I just do that I
just do it at my house boo yeah and I
make a lot of money Tada every parent
just wants their kid to be successful
not every parent some parents want them
to fail you be a lawyer oh yes well see
I come from a middle eastern culture and
so when you head into those you know
Eastern cultures there's a lot of
pressure of like if you're not a lawyer
an engineer or a doctor I don't know
what you are and I don't care cuz you've
disappointed me that exists like let me
call that out but I think a lot of
people were forced into that path hated
it maybe even are successful at it and
hate it which is somehow even worse cuz
you're like I can't leave this I'm you
know and that's a hard thing to do for
the reputation of the parents cuz they
can't go to their friends and go what
does your kid do you can't say he's a
doctor you have to say he's in the
liquidation e-commerce business he flips
half uh empty pallets but then you go
wait he's making more than a doctor
without going to med school sounds like
he's winning at life bro and then
they'll high five you and say good job
dad and then you'll get get to get to
beam a little bit there it is so drop
the reputation parents I just want a
successful kid with great character at
the end of the day today and uh Beck is
proven that this is the ramsy show we'll
be right
[Music]
back hey guys I've told you before about
Christian health care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
if you want to call in with your
question you can do that atle
5225 Jeremy's up next in Atlanta Georgia
Jeremy what is going
on hey hey George can you hear me I can
hey I'm I'm nervous so bear with me dude
it's just me and John it's just us SC
sitting next to George camell dudee I'm
nervous met you in October um I came to
um Dr John's book signing and I already
bought your book for me and all my
siblings George oh that's so kind thanks
for being a fan of ours man we're a fan
of you brother what's up man um
so I'll get to my question then I'll
give you some back story so how do I
help my dad who
is dying in front of my eyes um me and
my mom watched the live stream last
night and instead of watching it we
basically I'm I'm a Ramsey we're both
Ramsey followers and so instead of
watching it we actually just ended up
talking about life and I found out some
stuff I never found out about my dad um
and I I am my dad so I understand that
like I understand who he is um and he's
in a really dark place um he's 59
retired
military um and I my mom has tried to
help him for decades um and she kind of
ask me if I would I guess take on the
burden to help him um he he
has is that yeah that's kind of the
backstory so dude I just want to like
hop right in here dude um two important
things for you to hold very tightly to
your chest okay okay number one you are
not your dad part of him is inside of
you right but you're not him you are
different people different experiences
different life and all that kind of
stuff so you can feel like not I know
what's going through you don't okay
that's number one okay and hold that
very Loosely cuz if something happens to
him um and you start trying to get into
his head inside of his body and say no I
know I know it really shuts off a
dialogue between two people okay so he's
his own man and you are too you have
very you might have some similar traits
y'all might have some very similar
whatevers half of him is you but but
there we go here's number
two I'm going to walk you through like
how you can love your old man right now
but quote unquote handling the burden is
not your job you're his
son okay and if you walk into this as
he's a project he'll smell it a 100,000
miles away and you'll never get close
okay if you
decide dad you're 59 years old and I
want to start spending some time with
you
I love you and I don't even know you
that well could we start going to Coffee
once a month could we start fill in the
blank could we do this I want you in my
life if you have that conversation with
him uh now we got a whole different ball
game okay but if you go into it as he's
a project and I got to go save him
unless he is going to hurt himself right
if he is if he is suicidal then yeah I'm
I'm getting all in I'm getting all in
that mess right but short of that it's
more it's more he he goes to the motions
and he mopes around and he and he
commits F Financial
infidelity stuff like that is what he's
struggling with so if you come after
your dad with hey I heard you're
cheating on mom with your money and
stuff like like that's not going to go
well okay when's the last time you said
hey man uh I'd love to just start doing
something regular with
you um probably never exactly and hey
here's here's what's really scary about
this he might look at you and tell you
no h that's a possibility hey Dad I'd
love to have like a weekly coffee with
you I'll go to work late and I just want
to hang out what why why I dad because
you're my dad and I miss hanging out and
I don't even I want to hear some stories
I want to get your take on what's
happening in the world and I just you
need to get out of the house mom needs a
break from you m and uh you pay for the
coffee every time you pay for the
breakfast every time youall meet once a
week and he might tell you
no and maybe at that point you say I
love you and I want you to be around for
a long time and I sure would love to
hang out with you yeah I don't I don't
think I've ever heard him tell anyone he
loves him them when's the last time
anybody told
him that yeah that's I don't know okay I
mean I've never done it either okay
today's gonna be the day tomorrow's
gonna be the the
day I was can I give you a suggest so
I'm not I'm better at writing my
feelings down is that okay if I write
him a letter and read that letter to him
you can it's it's it's very very
effective but it's not as effective
okay okay I'm yeah I'm just worried
about him yeah and in his Decline and
it's not uh does he have any hobbies
Jeremy like what does he doing all day
yeah okay so right now he um so he owns
small business um that's a hobby store
so like Miniatures and um like magic be
gathering Pokemon cards or this is
George camel Paradise yes and but the I
think it his um his it passion project
that turned into business has turned
into a nightmare yeah and has turned
into more shame and guilt and then he
just makes bad
decisions ask family and friends for
money yeah doesn't pay back and then he
just Cycles into more shame and and then
I don't even know if he just enjoys it
anymore he works 50 hours a week doesn't
pay himself a g because he can't afford
it and what has the conversations been
with your your mom and your dad what are
they talking to to with each other like
is she addressing this with him going
hey honey we can't keep spending like
this yeah does she have a vote she has
so I think she has given up on him and
that she's tried her whole life from her
perspective and now she I think he in
her mind has lost his vote because he
makes bad decisions and she feels the B
she has felt the burden of being a
working mom and raising three
children and and she's still working
full time yeah yeah she's working
full-time getting her
PhD um she's a boss woman um and he kind
of just I'm not I mean she's even told
me she's thought about divorcing him um
when we were
teenagers here's the part that's hard
and I don't want to cut you off but
here's the part that's hard as a son
okay all of the things that you're
hearing might be 100%
true and if your dad was to really open
up with you he might tell you son 20
years with a woman that wouldn't let me
breathe she criticize like you see what
I'm saying so there's always going to be
another side to this and that's why I I
wouldn't get into the I'm trying to save
you because you got one side of a story
I'm not getting into to the dad you got
to just ship up and get right I would
get into the you're my dad and I'd like
to spend some time with you you see the
difference here yeah for sure um and
like Dad you're and I with my Dad we're
funny like we were pretty sarcastic with
each other and we always have been but I
would tell my dad dad you're old and
you're not going to be here forever and
um I'd like to still be able to talk to
you when you're before you before you
don't even know what I'm saying so let's
set up a weekly conversation
I got a lot to learn from you and then
maybe you can look him in the eye and
slip in there and I love you okay right
I mean I've lived at home for health
reasons as an adult and I don't mean to
know him and I've been at
home for 29 years and i' I I don't know
him and it just broke my heart last
night but I don't even know my own dad
yeah and maybe there's some shame that
his 29-year-old son still lives at home
and he wishes that he didn't have health
problems he wishes he was able to afford
for him to have his there's so much here
man um I'm just going to suggest to you
brother stay out of it stay out of it
and just tell your dad I love you and
I'd love to spend some time with you and
over time that's the shot you've got
that's the shot you got man it reminds
me I was watching Mike berbiglia's
special he's a comedian NX special he
talks about how his family never says I
love you and they say take care that's
their line he's like it's different he's
like I say I love you and they say take
care yeah and there I think how much
would that solve in America if we all
just said I love you and hugged each
other three simple words that are so
hard for us to say that cause so much
Discord and cause so much chaos yeah
yeah it's it's uh it's tough you talk
about this a lot just this lack of
connection that we have here's what I
can tell you I've sat with a lot of
people who would do anything for 30 more
seconds before their person passed to
just say I love you so say it say it say
it say it say it I love you John I love
you too George this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
host of the Dr John deloney show we're
taking your calls atle
5225 Jack is up next in Hartford
Connecticut Jack what's going
on good afternoon gentlemen how how are
you both doing great how can we help
fantastic I'm a fairly new listener uh
but I've already picked up one pretty
key piece of wisdom which is to pay down
debt I'm very fortunate to be working a
well-paying government job that I really
enjoy I have some cash and some
Investments but I also have some student
loans and I'm looking at the interest
rates on everything and weighing whether
to pay them off aggressively now or to
make minimum payments save more
aggressively and wait for that Public
Service uh Public Service student loan
forgiveness program at 10 years to to
wipe away the debt how far are you into
this 10-year
program yeah I'm about two years in how
old are
you
24 okay so let's fast forward to 32y Old
Jack where is he what is he
doing you know if things go well
probably about what I'm doing now I'm
I'm making good money I I like the work
and it's you know it's government so I
can't really be laid off which is nice
in times of economic stress
and what do you
make I'm making about 120,000 now and
that goes up somewhere between 5 and 10%
a year awesome so hey you said a bunch
of awesome things uh you're 24 right yes
sir all right I got I got two decades on
you you 100% can get laid off and you
can get furlo when the government starts
throwing uh uh me like tennis balls at
each other in the same box and they
won't pass a budget and so they let
things default and they they keep
getting paid but you guys don't it the
it it feels like ah I got security not
necessarily okay more security than most
and that's why you make less money
because you could probably make a lot
more money out in the open market um and
the perception is you'd have less
security
but yeah dude it's it's hold on with all
of your heart to your optimism um you
you'll become disillusioned soon enough
I'm proud of
you thanks the other factor in here Jack
is we're going to have two more
presidents before your debts are paid
off does that not blow your
mind that's kind of crazy yes and who
knows what the heck's going to happen
between now and eight years and if
there's a pandemic and what I just want
to be free faster you make 120k I mean
how much debt do you have so that that's
the kind of the mechanics of the
question is I have about 27,000 in debt
and I have about 30,000 sitting in uh in
cash in checkings and savings accounts
that get about 5% return which is a
higher percent than the interest rate on
the debt varies between three and 4.5%
but doing the math on that on the the
spread you're making I mean it's pennies
compared to your actual
income definitely what you're making in
savings versus what you're paying in
interest and I'm making $40 a month
spread that's $480 a year I can make
from this while carrying the stress and
the weight of this decision I mean it's
the fact that you're calling into the
show it's Weighing on you you know I I
think it's it's it's more like if if I'm
if I have the cash at any time I can pay
them off right and if I'm making more on
the cash than the interest rates on the
loans should I just wait for the 10
years and if you know God forbid I get
laid off next year I can just pull the
trigger and pay the pay the loans off
right away but am I crazy to kind of sit
and wait and see if I can hit that 10
year mark you're not crazy you're just
normal which is crazy to us in here cuz
we everyone says we're crazy cuz we're
like oh why would you want debt dude you
have the money pay it off be free and I
know some of these things have changed
um but depending on who's in office next
year is depending on whatever promise
they're going to make to
you and totally fair I had I I mean I
was the Dena students at a public law
school and I had a lot of really
brilliant students who decided to not go
do um big firm work and decided to be be
a public servant to help out their
communities because the government's
going to pay their loans back and yes
it's some of them have ended up coming
through but for a long long time none of
them got it they' apply they' apply
they' apply you promised you said hey
where is it and they're like yeah we're
not doing that
anymore and so here's what I'm telling
you just for me and my family I put zero
none in the hands of the government 10
years from now solving whatever mess
that I made for myself which is borrow a
bunch of
money very reasonable I I appreciate
that listen I'm also looking at a
pension plan and I've got a Roth and
everything but any parting words to a 24
yearold who's still figuring out the
world of personal
finance well number one um run the other
way where culture is going so you're so
glad you call this aren't you jack
here's the I opened the book with this
quote my new book Breaking Free from
broke it's from CS Lewis when the whole
world is running toward a cliff he who
is running in the opposite direction
appears to have lost his mind I think
the hardest part about the Ramsey plan
is this gnawing feeling that you're
going a weird direction that no one else
is going and it's so much harder to swim
upstream and everyone's making fun of
you going like dude you could make a
spread in your savings account why would
you pay off that low interest debt
you're an idiot that's what most of
culture is telling you on Tik Tok
right that's right and we're telling you
what if you could just have Peace and
Freedom today and every you make stays
with you instead of going back out to a
lender and you make different decisions
when you don't owe anyone anything and
you're not worried about the spread and
an interest rate and instead you're just
focused on your life and your family and
your career that's the life I want for
you it's it's Way Beyond math which is
hard to explain on
paper or I'm getting a vague sense of it
it does sound pretty nice let me like in
a more concrete way because you're a
very very smart guy like a brilliant guy
George and I will never we were just
talking about personal finance
conversation that we were having both in
our lives off
air interest rate never came up because
neither of us care about it neither of
us care about it I may have to move or I
may end up moving and I may have to take
a mortgage out on a house so we're
talking about the rate part I don't care
about could care less about it because
it's I'm not trying to play a rate game
as though somehow I can I can win a
completely rigged system if I put my toe
back in that in that world and I get a
mortgage for me and my family to move to
a different Community then I will put
all I mean I I'll hit the gas with all I
got to not have that Mor I could care
less because it's not about the interest
rate for me it's not about the math win
or loss it's about freedom for me nobody
will own me and my family and right now
I want you to think about it this way
you are in indentured servant
servanthood to the government for a
decade for all of human
history that was a catastrophic
punishment and this is one that you are
really trying to work hard to talk
yourself into
leaving you see what I'm
saying I do yeah know I see where I've
kind of gone astray the government owned
you for the next decade under this plan
otherwise you got the money right now
you could be free this weekend nobody
owns you
and then you're going to save up some
money because you make 120 Grand you're
going to save up some money and you're
going to get that 30 grand back filled
up and you're your own bank so you don't
care what the interest rates are because
you don't borrow money because you're
your own bank if you have an emergency
you just pay for yourself who cares and
now you're Off to the Races building
real
wealth phenomenal well thank you both so
much for the time I'll have to look into
that book really appreciate it yeah Jack
I'm going to I'm going to read you this
as we close this hour this is from the
student loans chapter of my book June of
2022 the pslf forms submitted were more
than a million and a half and 12,500
were approved that is a failure rate of
99.26% put another way it's a success
rate of 74% not even 1% were approved
and I saw one teacher post this really
depressing viral video John he said I
didn't get approved because I used a
slash instead of a dash for the on the
application and they said nope you
didn't fill it out according to our
terms so we're not going to forgive the
debt this is the bureaucratic game we're
playing we're waiting 10 years all to
find out a slasher Dash was the game
changer and by the way those 10 years
they're um making money on the interest
right if you're paying these things in
the meantime yeah so people's loans are
ballooning the balances are going up
over time because they're making minimum
payments doing income driven plans
thinking this is the path someone's
going to figure this out I'm telling you
you got to solve for Freedom man D and
you can be free today it's there's no
sacrifice involved here hang on the line
Jack we're going to send you George's
new book Breaking Free from broke and
you'll get it when it releases next week
love that that puts this hour of the
ramsy show in the books I'm George camel
he's John deloney thanks for
[Music]
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by author of the new
book building a non-anxious life Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls at
8825 5225 jump in and let's talk about
your money your life your relationships
whatever ails you whatever you're
excited about whatever conundrum you
find yourself in we're here to help you
take the right Next Step Grayson is in
Ontario Canada Grayson what's going on
in
Canada uh it's cold here I figured so
yeah it's cold here so um I'm 25 years
old um my take-home last year was
roughly
67,000 uh gross I still live at home I'm
a a single guy the only debt I have is
my truck um I made it this year my
commitment to stop spending money on
dumb things so far it's worked out all
right I haven't spent any dumb things
today this year yet it's payday today
and um I want to how do I stop the urge
of spending my money on dumb things
number one and number two is that I'm
getting a pretty big settlement within
the next uh two to three months uh
taxfree between
130,000 and
$140,000 um and I want that money to
work for me I really want to move out of
my parents house and buy myself a house
uh right now so that's my question to
you I have zero emergency fund by the
way I have like $5,000 in the bank so I
want
to make my uh financial situation secure
so George going to walk you through the
money stuff I want to give you two uh
bits of wisdom okay number one that's
actually my one of my New Year's
resolutions too stop buying dumb things
should be all of America's resolution
and Canada too even when I budget I just
buy dumb stuff so I am a th% with you
here's where you're going to get
yourself into a lot of
trouble this word you use urge how do I
get rid of the urge you
don't you
be disciplined and a grownup in spite of
the urge hopefully over time with um
month after month week after week day
after day year after year of new habits
and practicing doing something
differently the urge just kind of goes
away right like if I cannot eat gummy
candies for two weeks it's I've C I've
I've done the data on myself two weeks I
don't even feel the urge to eat them
anymore but dude that first two weeks is
brutal so the goal here isn't like cuz
here's what you're looking for you're
looking for motivation you're looking
for feelings it's not going to happen
you're going to have to be you're going
have to choose discipline the next right
action the next right thing does that
make sense okay yeah this that totally
does make sense so that means you have
to set up
systems that are going to help you be
successful and one of those systems is a
budget to where you go n that wasn't in
the plan not doing that this month if I
really want it I'll put it in the budget
for next month and see if I still want
it and usually you go yeah I don't even
care about a month from now it was that
urgency and that impulse I have a note
card with me that I write down things I
want to buy that I get an urge to
buy okay I had the same thing too now
that you're speaking of that if I if I
want it in a month like George just said
if I if I want it next time I come
around to budget cycle time I'll budget
for it I'm almost positive that of like
the seven things I've written down in
the first 12 days of January um I'm
going to get one of them and it's a
replacement it's something I I that got
lost during
travel yeah but I'm gonna set up a
system understand I try to spend my
money I try I try to look for decent
deals when I do even when I do want to
buy something dumb but still I just want
to
completely waste stop wasting money on
things that I don't need so part of the
way I grappled with this Grayson cuz I
remember living at home I had a
full-time job I was making bucks an hour
at the Apple Store and I was I
legitimately was like I wealthy I'm
crushing the game and I would blow every
paycheck on more music gear and more
discounted stuff through apple and I
realized later on I needed some problems
at 18 years old and that looked a lot
like moving across the country renting
and having bills to pay and I think you
heading into adult life don't wait just
move out and then you're going to go
crap I got to come up with 1,200 bucks
in rent I can't go blow a th000 on
random crap or if you're Ontario you
have to come up with
$185,000 a month for rent right yeah so
if you can't save money while at home
with no bills you're going to be screwed
if you keep up that up in the real
world yeah so I'm going to gift you a
few things that will help like delone
said you need some systems in your life
one of those is a budget so I'm going to
gift you every dollar premium so you can
get on a plan and go all right I made
$5,000 I need to spend less than $5,000
in order to keep up my life and that's
going to mean saying no to lot of things
and if it's not in the budget then you
just don't buy it and again that comes
down to discipline like John talked
about and John and I actually we co um
hosted a lesson in Financial Peace
University called why spending so I'm
going to gift you that as well to go
watch and that's going to help you
understand how your brain is causing you
to spend money how marketers and
companies are coming after your money
and get you on a plan to get control of
your life again when it comes to
spending and the last thing I'm going to
send you is a copy of my new new book
Breaking Free from broke cuz I wrote a
whole chapter called spending is
self-control and in that I walk you
through a smart spender Plan and there's
five questions here's the spark notes of
those questions it spells out the word
smart self-awareness is the first one
ask yourself this is this going to add
real value to my life will it add real
utility to my life if you answer yes
move on to M motive am I buying this for
the right reason is this just emotional
impulsive urgency retail therapy and if
the answer is yes then we got a
to that but if you can say yes I'm
buying it for the right reason move on
to the a for affordability is this in my
budget can I afford this in full in cash
right now if America answered that
correctly Grayson we would be zero
dollarss in debt and same for Canada
right so if you can say yes I can afford
it it's in the budget move on to the r
for research is this the best option the
best retailer the best price cuz I
haven't even Googled to find out we just
shopped impulsively and swiped up on the
Instagram ad and so that's going to help
you just pause and make a better
decision when it comes to that purchase
and if you can say yes it's the best
option retailer in price you move on to
the T for timing is now the time to buy
it this comes down to opportunity cost
Grayson's got a car to pay off so the
right time to spend on dumb stuff is not
for a long time until you can stomach it
when you're debt-free with an emergency
fund and you budgeted for it and then
that dumb thing doesn't feel so dumb it
just becomes oh I just wanted to buy it
and I had the cash and it's a it's I
spent out of my values and with the
right motives and can I tell you this
brother
uh I have just me being honest I've
really struggled to do this on my own
and so it it really is um my wife and I
using the every dollar app together so I
know when I buy something she sees it
immediately it pops up on her phone too
um I need that accountability I wish I
didn't but I need that accountability I
like that accountability um so maybe you
find somebody maybe I'll have to get my
mom to it I'll have to get my mom to get
that and she'll be like what the heck
are you spending your money on I told
you not to I mean you're a grown man so
maybe mommy's not the right person but
somebody in your life who uh can hold
you accountable right maybe it's a buddy
maybe uh George Campbell hang on the
line he'll give you a cell number you
can just call him anytime just kidding
don't do that well you should hang on
the line Grayson cuz we're going to send
you Financial Peace University every
dollar premium and I'm going to send you
the ebook of my new book Breaking Free
from broke so you can get a head start
on that before it comes out hang on the
line
man
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
joined by Dr John deloney I'm George
camel and we are your host today you can
give us a call at
8825 5225 and we'll talk about your
money and your life Grant is up next in
Columbia South Carolina Grant welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hey George and John hey how can we
help so I got a question my wife and I
have been written house for like 20
years and the guy was going to do a rent
to home and every time I mentioned it to
him he never done anything well now he
wants to sell the
house and
um you know we figured up over the years
we paid $68,000 on the
house the house is only valued at 34,000
and my wife loves the
house and now he wants to sell it and he
wants 35 for it would it be in our best
interest to go ahead and spend that
extra $ 35 ,000 and get the house that
my wife
like do you have
$35,000 no how much do you have I'll
have to get along well see we just got
started with y'all last week cool
and yeah I'm like
56 and I've only got like 8,000 saved up
in
401K what youall been doing
between uh living
life hard how much money do you guys
make well I figured between the two of
us we make
75,6 a
year okay that's a little higher than
the average income in America so that's
good but I'm wondering what the heck's
been going on with that income for the
last 20 years well I sat here figuring
that up earlier because you know y'all
talk about budget and everything so I
tried figuring out a budget and I was
coming up with that we spend $3,100 a
month on our budget you you know on our
on our
bills and that leaves me bleeding out
somewhere around $2,000 every month
that's America right there baby you
should work you should you should run
for Congress
man so so how much debt do you have
that's what we're talking about we need
to change yeah good hey I'm proud of you
brother good that's
big we we're right at $27,000 in debt
what kind of debt is that we had two
vehicles and a building a storage
building that we bought and a student
loan from where my son was in
college okay what's the storage unit
for for me to keep my tools and stuff in
do you do that for a living right
now yes I'm a maintenance technician
okay all right so what's left on these
cars building that we have at home you
know it's a building that we're buying
we only ow $1,300 on so we're fixing to
pay it off okay and these cars are any
of them worth selling or are they not
worth much and you don't knowe
much well I ow 3,000 on a
van and then we just got a Jeep couple
of months back and we owe 18,000 on it
o okay that's half your mortgage man
yeah I'm confused how this house is
$34,000 half America or 99% is going
where are they is the
trailer no it's a house it's a 19 it was
built in
1945 to see we live in a really
low uh economic area
yeah and so yeah our house is cheap well
good for you guys the good news is you
guys can get out of this Consumer Debt
fairly quickly making 75k the bad news
is you're not in a place to buy this
house okay it's just going to compound
the
problem so we just need to continue
renting until we get all of our debt
paid out yeah I mean you could make
you're making 75 you really get on that
every dollar budget you could pay off 27
using the debt snowball method where you
list your debts out smallest to largest
make minimum payments on all of them
except that smallest one is that the
storage facility for you guys yeah yeah
that's a storage building we figure we
have't paid off at the end of next month
hold on if you have 23,000 and you have
$188,000 Jeep if you sold that jeep does
that knock off most of your
debt yeah that would be most of is De
but I would do that man I would do that
tomor do this between you and a house if
the car is worth half of the house
you're renting I think you got too much
car so you could downgrade to a $5,000
$110,000 car right and you're in the
maintenance business you I bet you're
pretty handy all right so hey I want to
ask I'm gonna ask George a question
Grant on your behalf but I'm gonna ask
him okay so I want you to Eve drop this
conversation George we've got real clear
principles when it comes to like ratios
to buying houses
this house is
$35,000 it's less than most people's
cars exactly and so if if Grant went and
sold his Jeep and ended up with $5,000
he pays his thing off next month if he
was to go down and get a mortgage for a
$35,000 house with a $75,000 income I
mean he could have this whole thing paid
off I'm wondering I'm asking you is
there a because this is such an like so
far outside the bell curve situation m
is there a moment where you don't
normally get a $35,000 house and so if
if he'll have the courage to go sell
that jeep and knock his debt all the way
down there can he go and just buy
$35,000 house well the other issue is
there's no emergency fund here you guys
don't have anything in
savings just like $500 so that's the
part that worries me on a 1940s house
one thing goes wrong you guys are broke
and you're going to go back into debt to
solve this so I would see if you can
work out a deal with this guy and say
Hey listen give us 6 to n months we're
we're going to pay off our debt get an
emergency fund and then we're going to
buy this house off
you okay how urgent is this sale for
him um I'm not sure I mean he said he
wanted to sell it but he would I mean
he's been hanging on to it for two
decades now while you guys rent it right
yeah and it originally started to be
ours yeah this is this is the sad part
about it it originally started to be
ours we we had it we were buying it and
I lost my job and we were getting
foreclosed on
M and I was doing work for the man and
you know he saw that I was in a
conundrum and he asked me what was wrong
and I told him so he offered to buy the
house and he was going to sell it back
to us well you know 20 years later
man yeah I I I'm glad you have hope that
you can turn this thing around because
John and I believe you do and you're
going to get there but I would clean
this mess up first man get you sell the
Jeep get rid of the debt get an
emergency fun real quick then if you
want to take on I mean that that loan to
cover the house you're going to be
paying that off real quick as well so
within a few years you're completely
debt free no no house payment no more
payments and I I George I love the idea
of um Grant sitting down with his
landlord and saying okay in nine months
I'm gon to buy this house from you so
we're going to shake hands on it and um
Grant his wife get together and just
just hammer out this payoff this de get
rid of this dumb Jeep
there's a carrot dangling here I'm going
to take some extra shifts I'm going to
take my old van I'm going to deliver
pizzas with it whatever I got to do in
my community um it sounds like it's a
very low-income Community with $35,000
house I'm going to do whatever I have to
do to get this thing knocked out and
then get some money in the bank so that
I can buy this house yeah I truly see a
world in two and a half three years they
don't have a house payment no debt no
house payment emergency fund I love it
let's take a quick one here from
Danielle in Charlotte what's going on
Danielle hey thanks for taking my call
sure um my question is what is the best
way to pay extra on a mortgage to pay it
off quicker like to make an extra
payment mid Monon or just pay that extra
amount on the principal with my regular
monthly payment I love this question
I'll tell you the way I did it and that
was just to make an extra payment along
with my normal payment toward the
principal every single
month and try to keep it consistent set
a goal and say hey every month we're
going to do an extra thousand or we're
going to do double the mortgage payment
every month and try to beat your
personal best every single month but
there's a lot of Tik Tok out there about
the strategy and if you do you know 14
extra dollars by the end of the year
you'll have done an extra payment don't
over complicate it just throw as much as
you can along with your normal payment
if that's on the first just go ahead and
do it on the first you're not going to
you know hack the system by doing a you
know the the extra payment strategies
that you see on social
media okay how close are
you um we only owe a little under 73
actually about 725 is what we owe on it
11 years left on a 15E mortgage so I was
hoping to get it off sooner oh yeah dude
crush it you will get there so much
sooner and that's what I love about the
15E Danielle worst case it's under 15
but they like dang we could do it in 11
like dang we could do this in seven but
the 30 year you go well we got wiggle
room if we pay it off in 15 that'll be a
huge win so I love this aggressive
strategy you have to have total freedom
and most people following the baby steps
John we find they do it in seven years
on average yeah it's amazing get tired
of having it uh just hovering over you
right you a taste of Freedom with baby
step to and you're like let's just keep
going that's right love it thanks
Danielle this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George campel joined by Dr John deloney
and we've got some guests on the
debt-free stage Bo and Sarah join us how
are you guys so good we needed some pep
in our step and you guys are nervous at
all right we are stoked we're so excited
to be to talk to you honor where are you
guys from Lakeland Florida yeah Lakeland
near Tampa near Tampa sweet and here to
do your Deb free scream how much did you
guys pay off uh we paid off $30,000 in
11 months
woooo what was your range of income
during that time 49,000 to
104,000 okay did someone get a job or a
raise what happened yeah you want to
yeah
Sarah yeah Sarah got a job so we uh when
we got married she still had a year of
school left of her undergrad um and so
she worked uh two to three part-time
jobs and then I I worked full-time and I
was doing uh school at night wow all
right
and so what did you guys study and what
are you doing now oh so I work for a
nonprofit organization I'm basically
like a guidance counselor for higho
schoolers in a couple years out of high
school um but it's in our inner city um
of our city that we're from but I
studied biblical Ministry and counseling
and creative writing cool yeah and how
about you B uh John this one's for you I
work in uh Residence Life at of college
in Lakeland uh so I'm on call I know you
talk about being on call that's me uh
I'm also in the Army Reserves uh I did
RTC in college and I I studied the Bible
I'm um I'm in school to become a
chaplain in the Army so that's what I'm
that's what I'm working very cool so
they flashed your wedding pictures up
here you went uh all white shoes it's a
bold Choice wearing those shoes today
you guys oh yeah Special you guys the
same size share
shoes oh she had her own oh you had
your I was talking about B but way to
make it weird Sarah way to make it weird
way to make it weird so what kind of
debt was this
30k student loan debt yeah student loan
debt car debt and a little bit of credit
card debt just sprinkled on top for some
FL medical and medical debt yeah oh my
goodness wow and 11 months ago how long
you guys been married a year and a half
year and a half yeah so soon into this
marriage the honeymoon phase is over and
you guys are like we have no they're
still in it because see they're holding
hands with two hands still super like
and we plan to be we to be we all did
bro we all did I'm just kidding of
course you will of course you will all
right all right of course you will but
what happened 11 months ago that changed
things yeah so we were gifted uh
Financial Peace University as a wedding
gift uh so awesome we definitely had we
had dreams and goals but uh to be you
know rich and all that kind of stuff but
we didn't really know how that was going
to happen um but we were gifted
Financial Peace from uh a former boss of
mine Heather root I told her I would
shout her out um and we're so thankful
that she did so we we went to a church
once a week and took the class and um we
were sitting there we we were so we're
kind of young uh compared to um a lot of
the people that take the class and and
we were sitting there hearing these
stories of people who have gone through
so much and and they're in a a a really
deep hole and and they were right there
alongside us trying to pay off this Deb
um and so we were encouraged hearing
their stories and and Sarah and I like
we want to be um ridiculously generous
and um and to be a you know just like
everyone talks about here to be a
blessing to those around us or our
family and uh we saw this as our path so
during during that time we we started
off um you know cutting up the One
credit card that I had that I was
building credit with you know I thought
that's what I had to do to uh make
strides in life and Sarah had money set
aside she was much more prudent than I
uh and during that class we paid off my
car uh she had about
$9,000 saved up and and and we paid it
off right then
wow can I use your story as a really
important message for everybody
especially younger folks who are just
getting married just entering into the
workforce yeah on one hand you have this
picture we're going to we're going to be
wealthy we're going to do these kind of
vacations we're going to live in this
kind of home and on the other hand you
work in a nonprofit and you want to be a
chaplain right and so there's this
picture of this is these are the jobs we
want to do and this is what we want the
end result to look like and it's not
until you sit down in a class and you're
surrounded by people who are 20 30 years
into this and they've been making great
money and they're broke and you realize
yes oh my passion this thing I love
doing is not going to get me to this end
result unless we do something
drastically different it it's just
choosing oh this is what reality is
right and that's a that's a that's a
hard thing for most people most people
don't get it until they're 30 or 40 or
50 calling us desperate y'all figured
out really early good for y'all man it's
awesome we listen to the show all the
time and we hear those stories every day
and uh we hear um we hear Dave and
everybody say um that a budget is
telling your money where to go versus
wondering where it went and I feel like
that's been the difference oh for us is
so many of of our our friends people
that we know and stories that we heard
in that class were just like you know I
don't know how we ended up here but
we're here um but we started you know we
started off telling it where to go uh
versus wondering where it was going yeah
that's amazing what was the most
surprising part of these 11 months of
sacrifice for you guys the most
surprising part would be how well we
work together and how like communication
really can just be such a you y'all were
talking about how we're still in the
honeymoon phase like I genuinely think
that we're going to be in that for the
rest of our lives but it's because we
are on the same page not just about our
finances but along with everything in
life but importantly our finances we
hear we all talk about it all the time
Financial like pressure and stress is a
huge reason for divorce which that's
never a plan for us and so we wanted to
get to the root of that at the very
beginning of our marriage and so um it
was so surprising to just be in
communication with each other and see
how easy it could be if we know that
we're fighting for each other we're not
fighting against each other we are for
each other we we want to give to others
and it's all our money it's no one
person's money and things like that and
just being able to see how much better
that works Works um I think that was
something that surprised me I was just
like wow if we're just in communication
I've always heard this supposed to be
super difficult but this is actually
fairly easy when we are talking about it
every day and we're supportive of each
other and and I'm more of the nerd he's
the free spirit but you know he lets me
lead it sometimes in that and then I let
him lead where he's best and so
communicating about that was surprising
to find this is actually easier than
people make it out to be that's
beautiful and you got some leaders in
your life along the way there's some
weird people in the lobby hanging out
with you who are these people yes these
are two of our best friends Ashlin and
Tucker we're taking a Nashville trip
with them this weekend and so they were
super excited to be with us we we love
them support of friends can I apolog you
on one more thing sure yeah and if you
have to be watching this on YouTube to
to see it or on on social media but on
behalf of all of us who never really
understood George camel in those skinny
jeans thank you for bringing back back
jeans that uh Limp Biscuit would be
proud of that's that's my jam dude
that's my jam thank you thank you very
much thank you for that John had no clue
where you were going didn't know where
you're were going full jeno on that one
he jeno out he looks good they're
styling beautiful couple we're so happy
for you guys what do you tell people the
one thing is to become debt free what's
the key I would say well every dollar
budget is huge but then also we are
believers as you can probably tell so
just knowing that all of the money that
we have have is not ours we are blessed
with um you know bodies to work and this
money that we've been given and when we
Steward it well we're able to live with
an open hand and so that's one thing
that I would want everybody to know is
that being a good Steward of your money
and being a good Steward of your
finances um really you just see the Lord
work in amazing ways and yeah wonderful
say anything different well we've got
the living give box for you guys as our
gift to you baby steps millionaires
Total Money Makeover Financial Peace
University use it give it away bless
other people with it get them on the
journey so proud of you guys all right
here it is the moment we've been waiting
for Bo and Sarah
$330,000 paid off in 11 months making
$49 to
$104,000 count it down let's hear a
debt-free Scream 3 2 1 we're
[Music]
de
yeah that was cathartic that was
visceral John they're hugging they're
kissing gosh what a beautiful picture of
Love they're wearing clothes that fit
this is amazing
couple oh they are heroes we're so proud
of them and that kind of freedom is
available for you America whether you're
25 or 55 it's available and it is so
worth going after this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Dr John aloney
our scripture of the day Matthew 5:14
and 15 you are the light of the world a
town built on a hill cannot be hidden
neither do people light a lamp and put
it under a bowl instead they put it on a
stand and it gives light to everyone in
the house Jordan Peterson said you
should be better than you are but it's
not because you're worse than other
people it's because you're not
everything you should
be he's got away with words John he's
very smart you were on his show that's F
on show it's a great interview yeah and
hanging out with him in person is one of
the most
uh like the word that comes to mind it
it people are like what is one of the
most delightful human beings just a uh
very like a joyful kind presence and so
on on all of his Clips are always very
abrasive and this cerebral intense but
just in person just a very lovely guy
people say that about me too behind the
scenes hey before we take one more call
I want to remind everybody George
Campbell's brand new book coming out
January 16th that is Monday this is the
last weekend so you're you're either
listening to this live or you're going
to get this podcast tonight sometimes
Saturday sometimes Sunday this is it
Breaking Free from broke pre-order today
for only 20 bucks and get a 100 bucks in
free bonus items if you know anything
about George he's always looking for a
deal and so we made one that you can
what 4x 5x your your investment here 20
bucks and you get a hundred bucks of
stuff for free the last day to pre-order
this is Monday so go get it right now go
get it right now go get it right now go
to ramseys solutions.com
store s t o r e good spelling there John
I'm excited about it people already have
the ebook some people have the physical
book they found it in bookstores it got
shipped to them early and so it's cool
to see it out in the world in real life
and people are enjoying it and laughing
while learning about money and it's
making it simple versus complex for the
first time and that was my one goal so
I'm excited to to see how it helps
people very very cool all right let's
get to the phones Crystal joins us in
Portland Oregon Crystal welcome to the
Ramsey Show hey thanks gentlemen for
taking my call sure how can we
help um well I don't know how much of a
backstory you want but I'll just shoot
off my question and you guys can answer
love it
hopefully um it might be a a Dr D
question but I'm really wondering how do
I get over a poverty mindset when my
family is actually doing financially
well how do you uh how did you define
poverty
mindset well um I guess primarily the
fear of not having enough or that my
family will be destitute if I lo lost my
job um you know I I don't feel like
there's really any dollar amount per
year or in the bank that'll actually
make me feel better oh I love that good
for you you're right you're right so I'm
G to ask you a couple of like just
really simple yes or no
questions financially speaking are yall
leveraged to a point where if you did
lose your job yall would be destitute no
okay so you know that your body feels
one way but data facts of the situation
are something
else yes we are we are very fine okay so
here's I we don't talk about this very
much so actually what you're talking
about um I I tend to look at poverty as
like an identity right it's it's it's
very reality it's an economic issue but
it's it's a way somebody sees the world
what you're talking about is a scarcity
mindset there's never going to be enough
there's no amount that's going to fill
the the the bucket that you're trying to
fill as a hole in the bottom right yeah
and so what we don't often talk about
this and it's that's on me I don't talk
about it is you're experiencing two
things one this I'm assuming you grew up
in it was things were were was a was a
chaos extreme poverty on all forms of um
social services and my mother would
still give our like food stamps away for
drugs that's right that's right so you
don't have you don't have and I'm
talking about in your nervous system
your body doesn't know relational
stability it doesn't know economic
stability it doesn't know home stability
so all of this stuff is your body is
learning in real time you're changing
the oil on the car while you're flying
down the highway Fair yes all right
here's what we don't talk about about
enough you have after grinding it out
you got out Fair Crystal you got
out yeah I'm I'm I am more than I ever
thought I would be there you are and you
used that it was jet fuel it got you
here and then there's a scary thing that
you never anticipated and it's that you
don't trust you here you trusted you
when you were running but now that
you're here you don't trust you because
you have a disconnect between how you
feel and reality and you're smart enough
to know both of them and there's a huge
gap and you're sitting in the middle of
it and you realize oh when I was a kid
those
people had this kind of money not us not
me and it feels like you're wearing
somebody else's clothes every day
right that's a very good description yes
okay so I want to tell you a couple of
things all right number one
I'm so freaking proud of you if you were
here I would ask everybody to stop the
show and I would ask you permission to
give you a hug and I would hold on a
little bit past where it was
uncomfortable to where it was kind of
kind of like right and here's why I need
you
to understand how you have changed an
entire family tree CU you said
no and I don't think you fully exhaled
yet nope
not yet not yet if you don't exhale
you're going to run past the finish line
through the stands into the parking lot
and then you're going to run into
traffic you're going to get run
over so the habits that got you here the
grit determination the scratching and
clawing that got you here is going to be
the thing that blows up your marriage
and has people at work stop wanting to
be around
you okay that's me just being honest
with you cuz I love you
okay so what we have to do here is not
beat ourselves up because we don't have
the right mindset not hate ourselves
because we don't have character we don't
quote unquote feel right we just have to
say all right sweet you know what I've
never been a
millionaire and now I am so I'm going to
practice these new things and I'm going
I'm going to reverse engineer a new
identity I'm somebody who does really
well I've worked really hard and I've
been blessed I'm somebody whose family's
is okay I'm somebody whose husband's not
going to leave I'm a mom who's never
going to trade my kids food for
drugs and then I'm going to Exhale
because it feels weird to say
that is that
fair absolutely why is that hard for you
to
hear
um pattern the length of time I you know
it could be a number of things okay this
is in your nervous system be really
graceful with
yourself really graceful you're you're
so amazing it's you can't even see it
you can't even see it okay I'm going to
tell you something that has helped me
transition from growing up in a house
where things were really tough to a very
different adulthood and it's something I
learned as from not Dave Ramsey the Dave
Ramsey but my friend Dave like off air
and it's this idea of ratios okay
and when we had
nothing groceries cost X and there was a
ratio there now we make this much money
and the zeros look huge and the size of
the house looks huge and the mortgage
looks huge all these things look huge
we're just going to look at ratios how
much do I make how much do we have in
savings um what are we going to spend on
this car what are we going to spend on
this meal what are we going to spend on
this vacation what are we going to spend
on taking care of this family at our
local church who has nothing for
Christmas the ratios are going to guide
us because the numbers are they set off
every alarm that we have is that fair
yeah you're right I'm a little too
detail oriented there you go and when
you when you sit down to go I'm going to
buy this car and it's $50,000 your body
goes
$50,000 right and all we're going to do
is we're going to feel that we're going
to go yep trying to take care of me
again appreciate you and then we're
going to look at the ratios I make
$450,000 I can buy this $50,000 this
$50,000 car I got cash I'm good and I
gave away $100,000 last year we're doing
great I'm gonna buy this car you see how
the ratios will save you as you practice
yeah so Crystal practice that in your
budget force yourself not just to save
but to also spend and enjoy and to give
that is going to unlock some magical
things if you can learn to be generous
and learn that money is not a finite
resource and so I hope that helps these
are skills to practice yes and it's a
muscle you have to continually Flex in
that budget and I believe you'll get
there proud of you Crystal you're
amazing that puts this hour of the ramsy
show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Dr John deloney all the folks in
the booth keeping the show Flo and you
America until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and be wildly
[Applause]
[Music]
generous
oh